ich möchte
heute diesen
verwackelungs-prank machen da freue ich
mich übertrieben drauf das ist so ein
Command den kann man eingeben wenn man
im auf dem Server ist und dann wackelt
das ganze Bild bei Sandra dann wirkt es
so als wäre sie betrunken der ganze Bums
ist von Olaf Alter wo ist denn der nein
hier unten auch alles voll
olaf hat jetzt alles zugeschneit oder
wie ist der hier hinten gelaufen
danke schön
ist Olaf tot weil die Sache ist eine
Schnee Spur geht halt guck mal was
anderes
ja das Problem ist die Spur geht hier
lang
hier vorne ist er anscheinend lang
hier runter hier wieder hoch dann hier
runter
und hier ist ein Creeper explosionsloch
Scheiße wer war das denn mit dem Creeper
du wahrscheinlich ne du Lunge hast oder
Leute ich weiß nicht ist der Server auch
sich am aktualisieren wenn wir nicht
drauf sind weil es ist ja Multiplayer
Vogel
Sandra das f-wey Vogel ist ein v
[Musik]
nicht
warum denn Vogel Vogel wie ein F kann es
sein dass du dumm bist ja ab zu mir
ja das ist nämlich das Problem
natürlich kriegst du Ärger wo bist du
denn
Digger hast du neue Ausstattung ach so
oh das ist unsere Mitarbeiter
verwechselt wo bist du denn selfie wo
wohl
meistens wenn ich ein Problem mit dir
habe ist es hier wohl
ja was ist sag mal hier fehlt noch immer
die crafting Bench und hier fehlt noch
immer der offen
also
in Alaska oder irgendwie so
oder
[Musik]
weiß man das schon Kanada
Alaska oder Kanada
das wäre geil
ich habe das jetzt mal da reingepackt
die hört mich gerade nicht nur wenige
Minuten später
was für ein Telefon klingelt da was
Leute
hör mal was Leute hier
keine Ahnung was das für eine Musik ist
das hier irgendwo in unserem
villagerhaus oder so können die das
machen
[Musik]
der Spieler
hat lol ist das der Villager können die
neuerdings Musik spielen etwas länger
als nur wenige Minuten später
[Musik]
endlich zwei Monate haha
was ist das
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nein die hat die unseren unsere Musikbox
kaputt gemacht ja selber schuld Laser
ja hier deine Wurstbude
[Musik]
lass mich jetzt in Ruhe lass mich in
Ruhe
da nein
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wo ist die Musikbox woher soll ich das
denn wissen
ja scheiß auf dich einmal mit dem
schwungrigen Effekt an ihr selber
ja auf einmal kann ich sprinten Digger
Digger
ja Luca geh mal jetzt mal eine Höhle
und Sandy du musst es eine Einstellung
kurz vornehmen geh mal in Einstellungen
gerade geschrieben weil das die ein
bisschen nervt bei dir
geh mal auf Optionen
dann Chat Einstellungen und dann bei
Chat oben links musst du auf
so oft draufdrücken bis da versteckt
steht
Loch kommt Wasser
hier unten
Sandra
[Musik]
Sandra Sandra komm
hoch sprinten
[Musik]
ich könnte doch wirklich kotzen einfach
einmal mit Ey einmal mit Profis
du musst nur aufpassen hier tiefer wie
jetzt kommen Sandy
[Musik]
desto mehr von diesem neuen Monstern
kommen siehst du schon diese diese
Leuchten Tintenfische da unten
daneben ist Eisen siehst du das ja das
da ne du musst aufpassen bei diesen
Tintenfischen du darfst dich nicht von
denen
berühren lassen
[Musik]
okay was machen wir jetzt
ja Frage ist kriegst du das hin ja klar
Digger bin doch nicht dumm
komm schnell zurück komm schnell zurück
[Musik]
mir wird schwindelig ja das ist dieser
Tintenfisch wir haben es gesagt
[Musik]
was was ist ich kann nicht
mal hoch Leute
[Musik]
e
wie konnte das denn jetzt passieren
[Musik]